hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be examining the latest twists and turns
in the boku no hero story including the
showdown between a furious twice and a
double agent who betrayed his friendship
I will also address the psychotic return
of dobby to the forefront of the story
could this latest chapter be
foreshadowing a major hero death is the
war arc in boku no hero about to get
real and real deadly let's talk about it
right now if you enjoyed the boku no
hero content right here on the channel
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
animal roar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I get a lot of people
messaging me and saying that they don't
get notified about my videos but they
get all these recommendations for like
CNN and Jimmy Kimmel and stuff like that
that is because YouTube prioritizes big
corporate content over small independent
creators if you want to help us out and
make sure that you actually get notified
for our videos please go through the
trouble of clicking down notification
bell and selecting the option that says
all thank you so much
finally this video will of course
contain MHA manga spoilers I am breaking
down the very latest developments in the
story so please proceed with caution you
have been warned as part of their raid
on the liberation front mansion the
heroes appear to have located every
alternate exit point from the mansion
and its underground facility and sealed
it which makes the mansion itself the
only exit point that the Liberation
Front can now effectively use as read
estriol presides over an important
Liberation Front council meeting in the
underground facility with hundreds of
people in attendance
he suddenly learns that the heroes are
here the villain communication networks
have been jammed all the alternate exits
have been sealed and the mansion itself
has been surrounded by a large
contingent of heroes Reed Astros mood
instantly shifts from stress-free to
very very stray
and of course this activates his quirk
back on the outside of the mansion
Cement owes the absolute beast has
completely ravaged the building and the
heroes rushed the villains in what
quickly becomes an all-out brawl
the electric villain is surprised that
community was able to successfully
absorb his quirk and the villain tries
to up the voltage by using a bunch of
additional tasers however before this
villain can do anything
headshot Pierce's a hole in each of his
lungs and tells him that if he moves
around too much things could get really
really bad for him
very quickly due to his immense speed
headshot is able to do the same thing to
a bunch of other villains as well this
was pretty damn savage on the part of
edge shot either you do as he says or
you're in for a very very bad time
midnight then proceeds to use her quirk
to put a bunch of the villains to sleep
and calmly woods uses his lacquered
chains prison to take a bunch more
villains out of commission we see that
juzo hona new key from class 1 B is also
there using his softening ability to
take out a bunch of villains at the same
time by turning the ground to mud
mushroom girl from class 1 beat is there
as well and she is using her mushroom
quirk to cover a large area and again
she is able to take out a bunch of
villains at the same time this seems to
be a common thread when it comes to the
heroes and students who were selected
for the mansion attack in particular
they all seem to have quirks with the
potential to take out a bunch of
villains at the same time and the same
applies to both community and talk
Lambie their quirks also have the
potential to cover a wide area and take
out multiple villains at once
this strategy definitely makes sense
because the heroes always knew that they
were going to encounter hundreds of
villains at this location so they had to
come prepared the heroes who raided the
hospital have to deal with high-end nomu
but they don't have to deal with
literally hundreds of committed
Liberation Front villains trying to
fight them all at once with that said
personally I would have chosen edged
shot to back up miracle back at the
hospital instead of someone like crust
head shot speed and stealth would have
been perfect for locating and
infiltrating the secret lab in record
time and let's face it edge shot would
not have been stopped from enter
the lab as easily as crust but that's
just my own personal opinion clearly
edge shot is still extremely useful in
the mansion raid as well the action then
jumps back to the dramatic and emotional
confrontation between hawks and twice
hawks reveals that he was able to tell
the heroes when and how to attack using
coded messages and he was forced to act
now because the Liberation Front - just
kept getting stronger and twice his
newly unshackled quirk poses a major
threat to public safety Hawk says that
he had to keep a close eye on twice at
all times
and advising twice on liberation
ideology was a great way for Hawks to
stay close to twice as dozens of his
feathers point menacingly in twice as
direction Hawks warns the villain not to
resist Hawks doesn't want to kill twice
so he tells him to just keep still until
he can be taken into custody and handed
over to the police
if twice complies no one needs to get
hurt but just as I mentioned in my
previous boku no hero video twice values
his friends over everything else and he
already blames himself for the death of
Magnum because he was the one who
introduced overhaul to the league of
villains
when twice realizes that he trusted
Hawks and yet Hawks betrayed him and
used the information that twice gave him
to plan the hero raids the already
unstable villain completely loses it if
twice hadn't felt sorry for hawks
because of hawks is desired to be free
and if he hadn't trusted Hawks as a
friend the heroes would never have been
able to launch this attack and twice his
friends wouldn't be in danger right now
this infuriates twice beyond words he
blames himself for all of it and he is
desperate to make up for his foolishness
Hawks tries to be reasonable with twice
and he tells him that he is a good
person who was just dealt a bad hand in
life the nature of twice's quirk led to
profound mental instability and this
alienated twice from the rest of society
and eventually placed him square on the
road to becoming a villain Hawks
promises to help twice get back on his
feet and start a new life if he agrees
not to resist and if he just lets
himself be taken into
but twice refuses to listen he is
disgusted by the kind of so-called hero
that Hawks
is someone who is willing to lie and
deceive and betray people who were
supposed to be his friends Hawks tells
twice that he doesn't want to fight him
and he doesn't want to hurt him but
twice replies that it doesn't matter
what happens to him his existence is
dedicated to giving his comrades the
happiness they deserve and in that
moment he initiates the dreaded sad
man's parade super-move which allows
twice to keep cloning himself over and
over again until a single twice turns
into an entire army of twice's hawk
still feels bad for twice and he really
doesn't want to fight them but it
doesn't look like Hawks is going to have
much of a choice in the matter
not only is twice already initiating his
dreaded super move but the final panel
of the chapter reveals that a grinning
Dobby is seemingly on his way to where
twice and hogs are currently located
judging by the psychotic grin on his
face it is possible to Dobby suspected
something about hogs all along and he
now appears to be on a crazed mission to
find Hawks as I said in my previous
video I fear that Hawks his life is
currently in grave danger we all knew
that once twice realized that Hawks was
responsible for putting his comrades
from the league of villains in danger
twice would absolutely lose his mind he
would feel guilty about trusting Hawks
especially after what happened with
overhaul and he would make it his life's
mission to punish Hawks for his betrayal
now don't get me wrong
Hawks is one of the strongest heroes in
the world he is the number two ranked
pro hero in Japan Hawks is no joke and
even with twice's initiation of sad
man's parade Hawks can still use his
many flying feathers to take out dozens
of twice as clones at the same time but
Hawks has made it clear that he doesn't
want to kill twice Hawks is holding back
in this decision to hold back could end
up costing him dearly
twice does not feel any pity or sympathy
for Hawks now he wants revenge at all
cost and that's just
one part of this whole situation the
other part is the fact that Dobby looks
like he is about to pose a major threat
for hawks as well we haven't seen Dobby
in action in quite a while
and I am sure that Dobby is itching to
showcase his true power
now that the heroes have made the first
move what's more I am sure that Dobby
will be especially interested in making
sure that Hawkes gets what's coming to
him as strong as Hawks is his reluctance
to hurt twice after getting to know him
in recent months and the fact that he
may have to deal with both twice and
Dobby at the same time could spell
disaster for our young double agent we
haven't had many significant deaths in
boku no hero but with this war arc
heating up as much as it is I think that
some hero casualties are to be expected
and I am afraid that hawks might
actually be the first one I certainly
don't want it to happen but I definitely
can't rule it out
what do you guys think is Hawkes about
to regret holding back against twice and
could this be the beginning of the end
for Hawks how bad is sad man's parade
about to become and is the sheer number
of Twice clones going to overwhelm the
heroes despite their large numbers also
what was up with Dhabi's crazy grin does
he already know about hogs and is he
about to melt the number two hero's
wings just like the Sun melted the wings
of Icarus please feel free to share your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more Bokan or your content on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you have it to be new to
anime or or you just haven't had a
chance to subscribe please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime opera patrons
for making videos like this one possible
with YouTube constantly facing problems
left and right patron support means more
than ever thank you guys so much
first and foremost I want to thank our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including Ingram
a Lolan atom the world Steelers the
School Bus
Tyson korrina acquired respect and part
a heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
to your patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Odin Anatoly kazansky alpha do on
hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
cricket XP $30 beat Ted no Ted Colter
Joel Stanton very Gucci Jessica Kay
Lafond Alisha Akhter Emperor otaku and
JCCC walk up if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you please consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]